you completely devoted yourself to this
pursuit in a culture in which it's all
about hacks and shortcuts because when
you're 70 and you look back on El Cap
the memory of being on the peak probably
pales in comparison to thinking about
all those days of preparation that you
know that's the meaning of it for you
yeah well I mean the memory of being on
the peak is still very excited about it
but it is
so meaningful because of it because I've
spent years working on it years thinking
about it I mean for sure for sure I mean
that idea you know like what's the life
hack to Mastery and you're like oh the
whole by definition Mastery it takes
years and years you know just like life
hack it or whatever that stuff really
annoys me